scp-2000 is an unremarkable location it
is an old rarely used park ranger
station in yellowstone national park
it's in the middle of nowhere and it
gets deliveries of supplies from
helicopters and unmarked cars as needed
while a few civilians have attempted to
break in
none have been successful and scp-2000
remains undisturbed kept in plain sight
without anything seemingly important
about it but why is this one of the most
secure locations in scp history why is
it of the utmost importance that it
continue to exist no matter what the
answer may rest in a mysterious document
found in the most unlikely of locations
the marianas trench is the deepest point
on earth and the scp foundation has made
many trips there to investigate strange
phenomena but what they recovered on one
visit exposed one of the most closely
guarded secrets in foundation history it
was a document that had somehow survived
at the bottom of the ocean sealed in a
pipe and coated in wax to keep it
airtight and waterproof it appeared that
it had been packaged in such a way that
it could survive anything and that's
exactly what its rider wanted she wasn't
sure when the world had begun to end but
she could see it coming for a while she
looked out her window and saw all the
signs the seas were getting colder and
less hospitable to life the air was
getting warmer every year resources were
dwindling and the population was
increasing tensions were rising and
while no one knew just when it would
come almost everyone seemed sure that
the world or at least humanity would
reach its conclusion soon it was a
sinking ship that first really made it
clear things were going in the wrong
direction the disney magic was one of
the world's most popular cruise ships a
favorite vacation destination for
families it was also one of the most
carefully built ships as the company
prided itself on safety and had learned
well from past cruise ship tragedies so
the world was rightfully shocked when
one day it was announced that the ship
had sunk while pulling into port no one
knew what had happened and there was
something even more mysterious about
this tragedy no one seemed to have any
footage of the sinking despite
round-the-clock news coverage all the
pictures were of the ships still afloat
that is until the news companies
received a tape the networks were so
eager to play the footage that none of
them reviewed it first and the footage
went straight to air it showed the ship
moving along smoothly surrounded by
smaller boats when it suddenly stopped
it was as if it had been frozen in place
and the footage showed people on the
deck of the ship falling over from the
abrupt stop everything went silent and
then an odd foam emerged from behind the
boat everyone assumed it was the engine
having issues but it wasn't the engine
it was a massive arm at least a hundred
feet long and belonging to an eldritch
being just below the surface it reached
up grabbed the boat and ripped it open
like a piece of tissue paper the
thousands of people on board ran for
safety but there was nowhere they could
go jet zoomed overhead ready to attack
whatever the thing in the water was a
massive spiny figure started rearing up
out of the water and then the video went
blank the letter found in the marianas
trench continued to explain what
happened next the president quickly
declared a state of emergency and
implored everyone to stay calm
television networks were placed under
government control and were only allowed
to broadcast government sanctioned
information it wasn't long before the
internet became restricted too with
people prohibited from sharing
information that wasn't authorized the
government just kept telling people to
stay calm and go about their lives the
writer of the letter tried to follow
this advice and went to work and paid
her bills as if life was still normal
but all around her she saw terrified
faces and they were right to be scared
this was only the start of the crisis
that would soon grip the entire world
more and more strange things started
happening but none of them were tied to
the mysterious monster that had been
seen emerging from the sea towns were
evacuated because of rioting or placed
under quarantine after an outbreak of a
mysterious disease destruction was
blamed on terrorist attacks or wildfires
the writer's brother called her to tell
her that he had been forced out of his
home the reason was supposedly a
wildfire but he had gotten a chance to
look at the fire as he was being
evacuated and there was something odd
about it he could swear he saw a figure
of a man in the fire a man made of fire
and he was moving deliberately but she
couldn't ask any questions about what he
had seen because the call got dropped
and she never got to speak to her
brother again it was becoming harder and
harder to get any information about what
was happening with most news sources
shut down or under strict government
control there were only vague rumors for
her to latch onto people talked about
zombies ravaging the north about people
who seemed normal one moment losing
their minds and going on killing sprees
there were whispers of a doomsday called
rising up that was trying to stem the
apocalypse through human sacrifices
there was even talk about the ground
itself coming to life and eating people
it all sounded like one thing the end of
the world the letters writer tried to
stay sane keeping her information intake
to a minimum and attempting to go about
her life in as normal a way as she could
but it wouldn't be long before the
horrors outside came to find her and
they became impossible to ignore it was
early in the morning when she heard
screaming and gunshots outside she could
smell something burning and found blood
smeared on her window but she was too
scared to find out what was happening
she hid and waited for the noise to die
down soon the power and heating went out
and her water supply cut off not long
after she knew she would have to go
outside if she wanted to survive and she
wasn't prepared for what she would find
or rather what she wouldn't her house
was in a flat suburban area without any
major geographical landmarks so she
wasn't expecting to step outside and
find a massive cliff with the other side
nowhere to be seen not only did it look
like the rest of the world had fallen
away but she couldn't see the bottom of
the cliff it was like that half of the
world no longer existed what was left of
her neighborhood had been torn apart
with blood and destruction everywhere
and she seemed to be the only person
left had she been saved because she hid
or had the others taken the opportunity
to evacuate she didn't know but all the
houses around her had been abandoned she
was determined to survive and so she
took what supplies she needed from the
empty homes and retreated back to her
own it soon became clear though that
much more had changed than just the
geography of the world time itself
seemed to be slowing down the sun stood
still in the sky not moving from one
spot for days sometimes a heavy fog
would quickly roll in and render her
essentially blind but worst of all she
soon found that she was no longer alone
whatever had come into our neighborhood
now it wasn't human the first to come
were strange roughly man-sized metal
creatures then came the smaller
creatures like the one that looked like
a pill bug but one the size of a cat
this one seemed harmless at first but
then it looked at her and screamed stop
in a human voice but this was nothing
compared to what came next giant
blimp-like maggots with hundreds of eyes
they were ferocious predators landing
and eating anything inside she was sure
with all of these horrors that she must
be the only human left but one day after
one of the disgusting blimps passed by
she found someone else he looked like he
belonged to a swat team and was clearly
hurt seeing another human was enough to
spur her into action and she pulled him
to safety in her home he told her that
he had been hunting one of the blimp
maggots she told him that he was the
first person she had seen since the
cliff showed up in her neighborhood and
the rest of the world had disappeared
his response to this was odd though he
told her that the world hadn't
disappeared it had simply relocated but
couldn't tell her any more than that she
pressed him for more information and he
said that his orders really meant
nothing anymore he revealed that he
worked for a foundation that tracked
down strange and dangerous creatures and
captured them for research and to keep
the world safe but something had gone
wrong all the entities they had been
keeping contained had broken free at the
same time it was too late to reverse the
damage and the world had been declared a
gh0 dead greenhouse scenario the
foundation
had failed but there was a plan there
were still people alive but carefully
contained around the world in safe zones
the foundation had a way to reboot the
world including recreating people with
all the memories intact the foundation
would clear out the dangerous entities
repair the damage and use their
technology to put everything back as it
was this world would be gone but it
would be replaced with another one that
resembled itself exactly with no
memories of the horrors that had
occurred this couldn't be done right it
was impossible to sweep all of this away
he just smiled and said why not it's
been done before she didn't know when
the end would come she didn't even know
she would realize it was happening but
she didn't want to be forgotten so she
wrote her thoughts down and sealed them
in a tube she sealed the tube in wax and
waited maybe her house wouldn't be fully
destroyed maybe it would wind up
underwater as the man had briefly
mentioned maybe her message would endure
and be found one day as the last relic
of a world that had been wiped away she
wouldn't be around to see it but maybe
her world would be remembered the true
purpose of scp-2000 is the foundation's
most closely guarded secret a massive
underground facility designed to prevent
humanity's extinction able to produce a
hundred thousand humans per day it
contains memory banks that hold the
entire history of the human species and
all associated information but all
documentation regarding its initial
construction and history has been lost
though no one is sure whether this
information was lost in one of the
resets or by design the foundation has
made sure that scp-2000 will not be
breached the facility is guarded by
cognito hazards that will stop anyone
without the appropriate inoculation any
unauthorized access attempts are
considered grounds for instant
termination regardless of how high
ranking someone might be in the
foundation
scp-2000 is to the foundation what the
svalbard global seed vault is to
agriculture the failsafe in case
everything goes wrong that's why it has
the object class of thaumiel a rare
classification that is secret to all but
the highest levels of the foundation but
to almost everyone including every scp
foundation member who has never
encountered it
scp-2000 is just an old rarely used park
ranger station in yellowstone national
park with absolutely nothing unique
about it and no reason to look closer
and the foundation will ensure it stays
that way that's why when a letter was
found at the bottom of the marianas
trench that described one of these world
resetting scenarios a letter that pleads
to not let the world that existed before
be forgotten or hidden away the
foundation made sure with absolute
certainty that it would never see the
light of day now for more on scp
facilities check out scp-2000 deus ex
machina or the entire saga of scp-1730
and what happened at the mysterious
site-13